all dogs love to chew but what's a safe
chew toy to give your dog we check in
with dr jamie ogenstein the medical
director of oasis animal hospital in
henderson for answers
we have two very strong recommendations
one is
you should be able to take your
fingernail and create an indention
on what you're giving your dog to chew
and if you cannot do that
it is actually too hard and could
possibly break your dog's teeth and
people don't think it can happen but
trust me i've had pit bulls come in
with broken teeth and they're painful
the other recommendation we have is
to look on the treats if they're a good
treat that's for dental care
you can look for what's called the vohc
seals the veterinary oral health council
these are veterinarians veterinary
dentists who have come together and have
tested these products and they look for
certain things and once they say they're
good they put their stamp of approval on
it you can go to their website and
there's a list of all the things that
have their stamp of approval and those
are good things for them to chew on that
have been proven to help minimize tartar
i'm speaking of things that dogs like to
get their hands on of course scraps from
the table we've got thanksgiving right
around the corner
what should we avoid giving our pets
well and everybody likes to give things
off the table and i'm not one of those
veterinarians who tells you oh my god
that's a horrible thing to do i give my
dog treats but there's things to avoid
so obviously turkey bones
chicken bones those are bad the carcass
can actually cause problems the bones
can cause problems in the gi tract
um
the
grease drippings a lot of people like to
put a little on their their pet food
that can actually lead to pancreatitis
cases and they can end up in the
hospital very sick
same thing with if you have ham ham is a
very high fat meat um and then the bone
people like to give the ham bone
that can cause serious problems i've
seen dogs where they they
somehow swallow them and now you've got
an obstruction i even had a dog that it
got stuck
around this jar and couldn't get it off
we had to anesthetize that patient and
literally cut the bone off so be very
careful when you're giving bones